police in new mexico have made an arrest
after the recent murders of four muslim
men in albuquerque 51 year old muhammad
saeed has been charged with two of those
murders cbs news obtained the
surveillance video showing a person that
muslim leaders say appears to be the
suspect prior to the shootings omar
villafranca is in albuquerque omar good
morning did police say anything about a
possible motive
good morning police haven't been
specific on a motive and they're still
trying to figure out if the murders are
hate crimes detectives did search the
suspect's home and they say they found
evidence that basically says in their
words he knew the victims to some extent
for months the unsolved murders of four
muslim men had this community in
albuquerque on edge but in the end
police say a tip from someone here led
them to a suspect muhammad syed
you put faith in us you trusted us you
passed information on to us that was
crucial and that led for us to be able
to make
an arrest in this case police say syed
who is 51 and also muslim has now been
charged with the recent murders of aftab
hussein and muhammad afsal hussein syed
is also the primary suspect in the
killings of two other men muhammad zahir
ahmadi and naim hussein syed has been
taken into custody after a traffic stop
and police say a search of his home
yielded evidence connecting him to the
murders multiple firearms were recovered
from that home right now we believe that
at least one of them inside the home and
one of them inside the car that was
pulled over are matching to our two
crime scenes investigators say they
found evidence that suggests the suspect
may have known the victims and the
attacks might have been motivated by an
interpersonal conflict
cbs news has also obtained this video
showing who muslim leaders say appears
to be syed slashing tires in the parking
lot of a mosque after a dispute police
have not yet corroborated these images
this crime made our community feel like
he was under attack
we spoke with the brother of one of the
victims about the murder suspect
this is an act which is not done by
people who represent
this state and this city so this is
an outlier so i got relief that once an
individual is caught so we are in peace
even with the suspect in custody police
will keep up their patrols around
mosques and islamic centers here it's
also worth noting that investigators are
still working on potential charges
involving the two other homicides nancy
a relief for the muslim community that
someone is now behind bars omar thank
you